a New York City police officer is dead
after being ambushed overnight in the
Bronx the NYPD says the officer was
assassinated while in a parked mobile
command unit when 34 year old Alexander
bonds walked up and shot her in the head
police shot and killed bonds about a
block away Don de leurs at the scene of
this deadly ambush Don good morning good
morning police stepped up their patrols
in this area since March because of gang
activity the NYPD was out in full force
last night for the 4th of July
celebrations but just three hours after
the fireworks ended a routine shift up
the street from here turned into a
frantic situation an early-morning
police patrol was interrupted by a
violent ambush suspect alexander bonds
allegedly walked up to an NYPD mobile
command post window and opened fire are
striking mia so T's familia in the head
it is clear this was an unprovoked
attack on police officers who are
assigned to keep the people at his great
city safe she was sitting in in the
vehicle and he came up and fired around
into into the vehicle her frantic
partners desperate call for help came
moments after the shooting I saw like a
brawl happening in the police van like
someone was in there like a crazy guy
with a gun and then a cop got shot at
point-blank range
officer familia a 12 year NYPD veteran
and mother of three was rushed to st.
Barnabus hospital female police officer
attacked out of nowhere where Mayor Bill
DeBlasio said she was shot while doing a
job she loved she was on duty serving
this city protecting people the NYPD
released a picture of the gun allegedly
used in the shooting and called on the
public for help we can't do it by
ourselves we need each and every one of
us your help we need the media's help we
need the folks on the street corner we
need the people in the apartments we
always need your help to watch our backs
as we watch yours sources tell CBS News
bonds was out on parole
a robbery in Syracuse an innocent
bystander was injured in the shootout
with police but he is reportedly in
stable condition Rena Don thank you